Okay, the best way to go
about learning all of this
is to make a picture.
So, we'll work with a
device you've seen before:
The inside of a music box.
We'll be looking at
getting the right exposure;
that is capturing
the right amount
of light from your
device or sample
onto your camera setting
with your 105 lens.
So let's do this step-wise.
I've previously installed the
software specific to my camera.
So I'll open it up.
I keep my dock on the left.
I'll click on it, and,
lo and behold [LAUGHS],
I get a message that
no camera is detected.
[laugh] So now what?
I'm afraid I do this
a little too often,
something I want to alert
you to and then I forget.
Yes, I think it's a good idea
to turn your camera on for all
this to work.
So I'll do that.
Turn the camera on
and so here we go.
Our software opens up
and we see the screen
which finally gives me
the way to set exposure
settings to adjust the shutter
speed and aperture setting.
But first we're going to
go to another screen --
at least in this software '
giving me the ability to set
the ISO number.
I'll set it to the
lowest possible number
the cameral offers
so that we get
the finest picture possible.
And that's what we'll do
here: We'll set it to 200.
Now that number tells
the sensor how sensitive
it should be while letting in
the light from your material.
The higher you set the ISO
number, for example, 6400,
the more sensitive
you make your sensor.
In low-light conditions,
that could be the way to go,
but remember we have
control over our setup,
and, in principal, should
be able to add as much light
as we need.
But there is a problem when
you set your ISO number high:
The sensor becomes so
sensitive that it picks up
noise, electronic signals from
the circuitry in your camera.
The noise appears as graininess.
It's not digital information
from your subject.
And it's not what we want.
Take a look at the difference
between these two images.
One is set at 200 ISO,
pretty low number,
compared the other set at 6400.
The graininess of the 6400
ISO image is not what we want.
And by the way, I hope you
are viewing these images
on a computer or a tablet.
I'm not sure you'll
be able to pick up
the differences on a phone.
It's really significant.
In this software, we have to
go back to the first screen
to set the aperture,
which we'll do now.
We're going to set it at F/32.
For our purposes, we want as
much as possible in focus.
And notice down here that we
see F/32 indicated as well.
Okay, now we set
the shutter speed
which we decide while looking
at the exposure readout.
We're aiming for the
readout to indicate 0,
smack in the middle.
Notice it here in
the readout: not
under exposed, nor overexposed.
The exposure readout
is in fact very
similar to what you would
see in your viewfinder, just
easier to see, in my opinion.
And here's where
the tripod comes in.
You might have to set the
shutter speed at maybe a half
a second, for example.
Now I don't know about
you, but if I hand-held
the camera in that very
slow shutter speed,
the image would just not
be sharp when I blow it up.
See these two images,
one while I partially
hand-held, leaning the
camera on the tripod,
and the other with the camera
securely mounted on the tripod.
Quite a difference.
You'll have the luxury of
shooting at slow shutter speeds
without the worry of a quivering
camera if you use a tripod.
Okay, so I have set the ISO,
the aperture, and shutter speed,
and we will now click
on Live View, which
is another great thing
about the software.
We can see two things.
First, we see if we have to
make adjustments in composition,
to see if it's
straight, perhaps.
We also see the image with the
aperture setting we've set.
We see what is in focus.
Okay, we're ready to take the
picture and we click on Shoot.
The image is immediately
captured on the camera
and now watch while
the image immediately
downloads onto the computer.
Pretty fast!
Much faster these days
than it used to download.
And here, too, even with
this small thumbnail,
you can see if the exposure
is pretty much on target
and if your
composition is right.
Again, if the image
seems crooked,
you can go back and forth
and fix it in Live View
to make it work.
So let's review
the reasons why you
should consider using software
to adjust your exposure
setting.
First, you can easily see
your exposure settings.
Second, you can immediately
see if your settings are right.
Third, you can adjust
your composition
in Real Time and Live View.
And, that view is the aperture
you've set, showing you what is
and what is not in focus.
And fourth, you can
store the image directly
onto your computer without
worrying about storage
room on a camera card.
But again, if you choose
not to use a software,
all your exposure settings
can be made in your camera.
Just read your manual.